but first the USGS says a powerful 8.1
magnitude earthquake hit just off
Mexico's southern coast overnight
already at least 15 people are reported
dead and there is widespread damage the
quake triggered tsunami waves and
coastal evacuations video shows how the
earthquake caused violent shaking inside
an office building mexico's president
says the earthquake is the strongest to
hit his country in a century vladimir
duthiers of our streaming network cbsn
is following this disaster Vlad good
morning good morning Mexico's southern
most states are some of the poorest
regions in the country the earthquake
shook many of the buildings to the
ground and officials there are still
unaware how widespread the damage is
this video appears to show the moment
the massive 8.1 magnitude earthquake
struck off the coast of southern Mexico
people inside covering their heads as
the shaking continues rubble from
collapsed buildings in Chiapas littered
the streets as rescue workers shoveled
through the debris for survivors
reporter Jeff Paul of our CBS station
KTVT was in southern Mexico at the time
of the earthquake it felt like a train
was rolling beneath our feet and then
moments later that's when we starting to
see the buildings shaking from side to
side it sounded like pieces of metal
just scraping together video across the
border in Guatemala appears to show
power lines and transformers exploding
mexico's president Enrique Pena Nieto
told reporters they've already received
reports of loss of human life and damage
that cannot be quantified
hundreds of miles north in Mexico City
the earthquake shook office buildings
restaurants and even the famed Angel of
Independence Monument frightened people
ran from their homes worried they could
collapse I realized it was an earthquake
right away Mexico City resident Alonzo
Kanawha said it was very strong
Mexico's president says they will assess
damage to life and property in the
coming days the USGS says an earthquake
like this was expected in this part of
the world because of how the tectonic
plates move under the Mexican Peninsula
Nora
all right Vlad thank you